في العيد العشرين للعربيه بقول عقبال 100
سنه
وبنوعد المشاهدين انه نكون على قدر
المسؤوليه اللي اعطونا اياها حتى يكونوا
اوفياء لنا في عشرين سنه راحت وان شاء
الله
العشرينات السنوات الجايه بعشرين سنه
مرقنا بتجارب مهمه جدا وغنيه مهنيا
واعطينا العربيه احلى سنين عورنا بعيد
العربيه العشرين بقول شكرا من القلب صعب
انه الواحد يتكلم يعني عن العربيه وخصوصا
في عيدها العشرين
هي كبرت
وبرغم ان روحها دائما العربيه روح صغيره
ورشيقه لكن النجاحات اللي حققتها كبيره كل
سنه العربيه بالف خير كل سنه وهي دائما في
الرياضه كل سنه وهي مستمره في دورها
الاخباري التثقيفي كل عام والعربيه وكل
اسره العربيه بخير بنجاح بالمزيد من
الازدهار والتقدم